hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in the loggia chapter a st. Anselm is
going to discuss a doctrine which is
coming from Christians a lot in
philosophical terms particularly in
terms of metaphysics in terms of
causality where things came from and
he's really grappling with one of the
great metaphysical questions where did
things come from and the answer is in
part of these from nothing now there is
a being from which these things are
going to derive as we've seen in the
previous core concept videos if you read
through the previous chapters and some
is talking about a Supreme Being which
is the you know apex you might say on
being and he has asserted in Chapter 7
that his Supreme Being creates all
things from nothing as a matter of fact
he's done a beautiful passage here after
he discusses matter the questions well
where does the matter come from so we're
going
that site he says here we go there's
undoubtedly nothing more evident than
this the supreme essence alone through
itself produced so great a mass of
things so numerous a multitude so
beautifully formed so orderly in its
variety so fitting in its diversity from
nothing so the idea is that that the
supreme assam so we call that God is
creating the totality of things not just
you know first like you know making
imagine that that matters a bunch of you
know Legos or bricks blocks or you know
Lincoln Logs whatever you like tinker
toys and making all that stuff and then
forming everything else but rather in
some sense the totality is being created
now there's a very complex metaphysics
there that we can't go into great detail
about at this point without going way
beyond the boundaries of this particular
video but suffice it to say that's what
I am is interested in investigating in
understanding in talking about this
doctrine of creation or making beings ex
nihilo out of nothing from nothing so he
starts out by reaffirming this and then
he says alright how does this ish think
make sense how does the Supreme Being
create things of nothing he says what a
thing is made whatever the thing is made
from is a clause of the thing that is
made from it and necessarily every
clause contributes some help towards the
existence of the effect now why is that
a problem or why is that a puzzle if
we're saying that we're creating things
from nothing then it looks like nothing
in a certain sense is a cause for the
effect of creative things so we have to
investigate what do we mean by nothing
and here's where he handsome does some
some pretty interesting
discussion now his conception of nothing
is not exactly the same as every other
person who's who's talked about nothing
so no sense leaving comments you know
merely telling me about somebody else's
conception nothing let's see what and
some himself he has to say he says
nothing either signifies something or
does not signify anything now can it be
something can nothing be the kind of
something he says if nothing is
something whatever is made from nothing
was made from something so that doesn't
get us anywhere we already understand
how things are made from something on
the other hand if nothing is not
anything then since it's inconceivable
that something is made from what does
not exist at all nothing is made from
nothing as the saying goes so it seems
to follow that whatever exists was was
in fact made from something since it was
either made from something or from
nothing then we just saw there's a
branching offer for nothing so he says
therefore whatever nothing is whether
nothing is something where is not
something it seems to follow whatever is
made is made from something but if we
accept that that contradicts what we
started with so we we want to figure out
that is there some way that we can
conceptualize what nothing is and what
making something from nothing is so then
this will actually make sense so it's
not the Supreme Being actually creating
things from from something safer matter
that that you know pre-exists or any of
these other cosmological explanations
that were around at the time so he
assumed says well this is very typical
handsome making a distinction between
several different senses of an
expression he says there's three senses
of this phrase or expression made from
nothing
that's needle of octave right so one of
these is that
a thing has not been made at all he says
one way is that we mean what is said to
have been made from nothing he hasn't
been made at all it's like a case here
you give some examples in which a person
is asked what are they thinking about
because we're not saying I think and
they say I'm nothing I'm thinking about
nothing what do they mean I'm not
thinking about anything there's nothing
there's no thing
no something that I haven't thought I'm
not actually thinking period and so he
says in this sense of someone where they
asked about the supreme essence himself
or something that did not and does not
exist at all what has it been made from
one could in fact correct the answer
from nothing that is it was not made at
all so that that applies to nothing
itself nothing hasn't been made there's
no making of nothing right I suppose you
could make something into nothing but
that's not the same thing as making
nothing and the supreme being has not
been made at all either the supreme
being it just is the supreme being and
it's what everything else gets gets me
from as a causal thing so that's not the
sense that we're looking at in terms of
saying that that create the supreme
being creates all things from nothing
but it's an interesting sense what about
the second idea a thing is made from
nothing as if nothing actually is
something well that is what we're
talking about just a bit before so he
says if something is said to have been
made from nothing in the sense that it
was made from nothing itself that is
from what does not it all exist as if
nothing itself or some existing thing
from which something could be made the
Anselm said that's absurd
there's there's an inherent you know
contradiction or absurdity in to that
it's not going to work so what's the
third option
here's wherever he has a particularly
interesting way of thinking about things
the thing is indeed made this is going
to be integral to an slums metaphysics
the thing is made but there is not
anything from which it is made so he
says it seems we use a similar meaning
when we say that someone who is upset
for no reason is upset about nothing
and notice there is a difference there
between the example that he gave up what
are you thinking of I'm thinking about
nothing and being upset about about
nothing he says if we understand our
earlier inclusion in this sense that all
existing things other than the supreme
essence were made by him from nothing
that is they were not made from anything
there isn't anything from which they
were made in the sense of being given
you know their their full being he says
nothing illogical will follow from that
so that is the one that is the
explanation that we want to pick when
God or the supreme essence the supreme
being whatever you want to call it
creates everything from nothing God or
the Supreme Being simply creates there
isn't any any you know pre-existing you
know shaping play no physical clay or
anything like that from which the stuff
has to be made because remember God
makes the matter as well the the matter
that everything else is made yeah and
sometimes you know emoted natural
science which we don't have to worry
about but it wasn't so work in the
present day now he says something after
that that this is this final point and
that could be rather confusing so the
goal of these core concept videos is to
try to make these very interest
philosophical passages a little bit less
obscure this is one of those things
where if you haven't been reading an
Psalm for a while you might not exactly
understand what he's getting in so he
says it would be logical and free from
absurdity to say that the things were
that were made by the creating substance
were made from nothing in the sense so
he's making a comparison here in which
we will often say that someone has come
from poverty to wealth or from sickness
to health that is he who once was poor
is now rich which he was not before and
he who once was sick is now healthy
which he was not before now is this a
perfect analogy no why because you can
say well what we're talking about here
is not you know being a being who is
sick and being a being who is healthy or
poor and then rich but rather whether
you exist at all and so it seems like
there might be a big divide between
those and some thinks of sickness or
poverty or other terms like this like
blindness is privations they're not the
same thing as nothing but you might say
they're approaching nothing depending on
how far along they go so when when the
Supreme Being creates from nothing he is
taking things from non-being into being
and you might say well that presents a
problem how does he know what he's
actually taking from non-paying we're
going to talk about that in the next
video because it's discussed in the next
couple chapters here's where it's really
important he says if it said that the
creating essence made all things from
nothing or that all things were made by
him from nothing
statements can be understood in this
sense that the things that once were
nothing are something the expression he
made them or they were made is
understood to means very important that
when he made them he made something he
didn't just take nothing and turn
nothing into two you know some other
kind of nothing
he makes determinate beings that
actually are some thing and they are
what they are not some other being so he
says when we see someone who some man is
raised from a very lowly state of great
riches or honors and say look at that
man made him from nothing or he was made
from nothing by that man that is he who
once was regarded as nothing is now
thought to be truly something because a
man has made itself now and some is not
saying that there's a strict equality
here that this is exactly the same thing
but he does think that that analogy can
help us wrap our heads around what it
means for the you know the creative
divine Supreme Being making things out
of nothing that ex nihilo